i would imagine he feels quite torn part
of him wants to stay and of course
be there to support the queen i'm sure
he'd love to be here for her birthday
but i think there's also a part of him
that is understandably keen to get back
to his
heavily present wife and his little boy
prince harry is back in the u.s
following prince philip's funeral
meanwhile prince william and kate
middleton
just paid tribute to the late royal and
queen elizabeth released a rare personal
message
on her 95th birthday i think people are
hoping that
in all of this very sad story that there
may be a silver lining and that will be
that william and harry can start to talk
about things
and hopefully put the past behind them
and move on
suddenly i think that's what the duke of
edinburgh would have wanted he loved
william and harry and he would have
hated to have seen them
fall out e.t can confirm the 36 year old
duke of sussex
is back in montecito california
following his trip to the united
kingdom for his grandfather's funeral on
monday royal expert katie nicole told
et that harry would be arriving back in
the states to reunite with his wife
meghan markle and their son archie of
course
megan is pregnant with her and terry's
second child and was not given medical
clearance to travel overseas
so harry made the trip solo landing in
the uk
on april 11th marking his first visit
back
since he and megan stepped down as
senior members of the royal family
last year they haven't actually seen
each other now for over a year
so this is the first real opportunity
that they are going to have
to sit down together and talk
and hopefully start to
build a better relationship harry
attended his grandfather's funeral on
saturday
and spent time chatting with his brother
prince william
they were very tense as they walked into
that chapel
as they came out of it you could see
some of that
tension diffuse and i think that was
largely down to the duchess of cambridge
who made a point of speaking to harry
and when she did that you could see him
visibly relaxed
both william and harry took part in the
procession behind prince philip's coffin
on the way to st george's chapel and
camera snapped
william kate and harry walking together
before kate stepped back to give the
brother some space
it's always been my understanding that
behind the scenes
kate has tried very hard to forge a
rapprochement and act of the peacemaker
between william and harry you know she
loves harry
he said she's the sister that he never
had she's been heartbroken
to see them fall out and i think she is
one of the very few people
one of the few family members who was
actually able to
push the brothers together which you
know she did in a very subtle way
but it was very effective as for kate
and william
they are continuing to honor prince
philip following his death
on wednesday the couple visited the air
cadets 282 east ham squadron
kate took over the royal patronage for
the air cadets from philip in 2015
before he retired from his royal duties
a few years later
and she became an honorary air
commandant
that's the duke and duchess of cambridge
wearing black in a show of mourning
smiling as the squadron paid tribute to
philip prince minute was ultimately a
family man
he wanted the royal family to be united
wednesday also marks queen elizabeth ii
95th birthday and while her royal
highness
won't be hosting a celebration this year
as she remains in mourning after the
death of her husband of 73 years
she did share a rare personal message
with the public
quote my family and i would like to
thank you all for the support and
kindness shown to us
in recent days we have been deeply
touched and continue to be reminded that
philip had
such an extraordinary impact on
countless people throughout his life
[Music]